[Music]
over the years demand for rice has been
growing or into increased demand for
alternative carbohydrates and
progressive change in eating habits
in 2019 kenya imported rice worth 25
billion shillings the annual rice
consumption is increasing at a rate of
12 percent compared to four percent for
wheat and one percent for maize which is
a main step of food previously regarded
as an orphan crop the government
declared rice an important crop to
supplement maize and in 2008 launched
the kenyan national rice development
strategy to double rice production in
the country as the demand for rice
increases farmers are becoming more
aware of the environment farmers like
dan from west corner irrigations came in
western kenya and gare from moya
irrigation scheme in eastern kenya have
been growing rise for decades initially
my father is the one who was
holding these farms after he was dead he
has died
i'm the one who took over from him i
have four acreage of
farm
and i'm doing rice when this
rise this farm was budging the
production of rice was the hill was very
high
and we
one acre was producing almost
60 to
70 bucks
but
nowadays
it goes down i've been a rice farmer for
quite a long time i inherited these
farms from
my father who was a the original roti
and i've grown here
since
i was young
and i've been doing this
together with my father then i took over
i've done it for several years we plan
to rise around august
we harvest
late november and december
then after that
we do what we call ratoon
latune is a when when we cut the rice
another crop sprouts and
we treat it just like a
normal
crop and then it grows we harvest then
after that
our farms remain idle
for quite some time before we embark on
the next cropping season these farmers
are just a sneak peek into what other
rice farmers have been practicing for
many years globally rice is known to be
a key contributor to greenhouse gas
emissions and climate change owing to
the large volumes of fertilizers and
water that rice requires
by promoting water and nutrient-use
efficiency the concept plays a critical
role in the reduction of these gases
towards helping combat effects of
climate change the rice sector is one of
the largest or the the fastest growing
agricultural sub sectors in in kenya
and actually across the world because in
terms of
consumption
in terms of cereals actually it's almost
now overtaking ways here in kenya with
an annual growth rate of about slightly
over 12 percent per annum which is a way
beyond the consumption growth rate for
both the wheat
maize
and other cereals so you can imagine how
serious this particular commodity is
because even of the
import
import bill on
on rise particularly here in kenya we
are the largest importers of rise in
east africa
and therefore
the importance of rise
subsector cannot be cannot be again said
and for that reason
you can imagine there's a lot of there
are a lot of efforts geared towards a
rice production
and sometimes
we may risk doing rise intensification
at the expense of the environment
and of course you can imagine the kind
of
the amount of
pressure
rice production puts on
on the environment and of course
and its effect on climate because
of the
the greenhouse gases that are produced
within the the rice production fields
particularly methane and other
greenhouse gases it is on this backdrop
that kilima trust has ambassador's
journey to support the two rice grain
regions in kenya that is eastern and
western regions for cross-learning
opportunities to introduce regenerative
agriculture through sustainable rice
cultivation rotational cropping with
leguminous crops and management of crop
waste streams the project is funded by a
care foundation and seeks to foster
public and private partnerships along
this value chain
the ultimate goal is to promote the use
of innovative technologies and generate
evidence of developed and tested
business models for scaling up as it
also boosts farmers production
capacities
we came up with this
particular project called
reduce
reuse
recycle
rice initiative
furthered by the ikea foundation of the
netherlands and it's geared towards
ensuring that
there is increased adoption of
sustainable rice production practices
and also adopt regenerative or what you
call circular economy within the
subsector according to research by
eagerton university despite my
irrigation scheme being more intensive
in comparison to western kenya the
yields per acre are considerably lower
but why is this a situation what is very
clearing is that
is more advanced
in the marketing market linkages
and the orientation of farmers to
innovations in the value chain
and therefore they have well organized
marketing system they have
the farmers are highly linked to
marketing processing there are several
meals up to 15 i think
as compared to aero a hero is
not well established in terms of the
western western kenya
in terms of the value chain and
innovations so
but the difference is that the
productivity in western kenya is higher
so with the intensification in eastern
kenya where farmers don't allow the the
farm to rest
continuous
irrigated irrigated system does not
allow the soil to breed
so
continuous eboxy conditions does not
allow microorganisms to survive because
there is no oxygen for nine months in a
year so in western western west kenya
the farmers produce at least once one
crop plus an additional
mini crop
so the rest of the time is a rest period
for the farm
so nutrient content the soil organic
matter the
the overall production system is better
in western kenya at the production stage
overuse of fertilizer in the fields has
been a challenge to address this millers
like moirai's grow as multi-purpose
cooperative society has adopted the urea
displacement system where nitrogenous
fertilizers like urea are applied in a
more efficient way on the other hand
input providers like margo enterprises
in western kenya can already see great
uptick of the pelleted urea by the
farmers the nitrogen advertiser found in
the market is in granule form
and that granule forms all those
granules are the ones which are applied
by the farmer through broadcasting so we
have realized the cost of applying and
the amount of waters are being applied
is too high
now through the four hour program
they have financed us
to compact those granules
into parrots
thereby reducing
the amount of waterizer being applied
into the field
of course also reducing the cost so when
you go to apply into the chamber we
don't broadcast what we shall do we are
going to apply them deeper into the soil
through that method of urea deep
placement
this fertilizer is slow release and most
the demos that we have done is just a
one-off application after 21 days we did
21 days and when we applied this and
it's just enough for that farmer
for the whole production process
and with that in the directory that we
have we have increased from a production
to two to thirty percent
and now the adoption is really coming up
i can proudly say i've already sold up
to
around
800 bags of this
and if you visit some of our farmers in
gonialla
you in west kennel
and
andajero will be able to find that now
they understand the use of
the pelleted urea as a way of increasing
rice production in addition to improved
fertilizer application the project is
also intensifying adoption of crop
rotation where farmers intercrop with
leguminous crops like green grams which
are excellent for nitrogen fixation when
we are doing the cooperation
the yield starts to grow up again
we do
green grams
after green grams we do rice
when we put rice
when we put green grams we can even get
more money
like the one i did myself i did i get a
lot of money from the green grams
it supported me in school fees
in hospital
even in some other things
it helped me a lot
beyond the rice grain rice husks and
straws are made by products in rice
production the straws contain silica
which takes much longer to decompose
leaving farmers with limited options on
how to utilize them they end up either
being burnt or fed to livestock despite
their low nutrition value to address
this the r4i csa project in partnership
with eagerton university has piloted
vermicomposting where red worms are used
to break down the straws into rich
organic manure and vermi liquid which
farmers can use on their farm or even
sell the straw from rice has got a lot
of silica
there is a uptake of silica in the straw
and therefore they cannot easily be
biodegradable the worms plays a very
important role
they introduce hydrolytic enzymes into
the straw so we mix together with the
organic mat organic matter from cow dung
and within a period of 60 days
all this straw now has been biodegraded
from through the
mechanisms of hydrolytic enzymes and
also the the red worms are very very
active they feed also on this and within
a short time
if you leave them in the farm without
doing family composting you will come
back after 90 days and you still get it
as hard as it is without breaking down
so that is why you see most of the rice
production systems one of the biggest
problems is what to do with the straw
rice husks on the other hand have been a
menace to millers for a very long time
they account for the bulk of waste at
the point of milling in a period of one
month
we are able to
mail
exactly about eight thousand kilograms
and out of eight thousand kilograms rice
ass is about
kilograms we had a charge
a particularly on the space for keeping
this rice husk
because a
250 metric tons
is much much much husk
and
we used to
ban that task
initially
but due to the preparation growth and
the scarcity of space particularly in
moya
we don't have any space where we can
take this husk and burn
but tables are turning rice husks are
now becoming a sought after input in
production of diverse products from
fabrication of stoves that use rice
husks carbonation of husks for
production of organic fertilizer to
reach organic material for tree
nurseries the opportunities are many we
started working on this innovation
because as you when you walk around you
find a lot of waste that are just dumped
outside
and uh most of you are propelled by the
amount of waste that was coming out of
this small town
and so we were seeing the dump site
which has been a very big problem even
to the government on how to dispose the
waste
so we realized that a lot of waste that
were being disposed there
are combustible waste and so we're
thinking on a way on how we can turn
this waste into
um
energy and that's why we came up with
this kind of stuff
that then could be used to
burn that waste to
to
energy at the same time
help in management of those waste this
innovation is gradually taking shape
with women adopting it as an alternative
to using firewood
over 10 youth who have learned how to
add value to rice husks kilimotras has
helped create linkages for them with
more rice growers where they get the
rice asks for carbonation to make
biochar
cream
synthetic
ready to use for farmers as mulching
material but it doesn't end here
kilimotrust has linked to awareo with
safyorganix an organics fertilizer
manufacturer which uses the shared husks
for production of organic fertilizers
initially actually we were doing the
whole process here
so we will do the carbonization here but
now we realized that
it is
one of the bottlenecks
and definitely
was taking quite a lot of time and also
limiting our capacity
so what happened is we chose
to look for
people
to work with and people we can train
on how to convert their rice husk into
biochar
so and
one of the things that happened
interestingly then
climate trust was also
in the picture so we brought
people like uh on board
we have about six teams that are doing
that for us
and
the good news is the these people are
able to win
a good income
from the venture
which i would otherwise
they would otherwise have moved to urban
centers to look for jobs so we are
reducing that
in directory we say at sophie organics
we are employing about that youths
locally with eastern kenya having
intensified value addition companies
like lake basin agritech are working
towards knowledge transfer in the
western region the cost of producing
rice is too high
and most of that cost is actually taken
by a fertilizer so this is the reason
why we decided to look for which are
other cheaper ways
of
improving soil fertility in rice
production
and
we also learned from
our colleagues in in
safe organics
which
was already in the field of
biochar production so our intention
was to replicate the same
in western kenya because we had seen the
impact that
biochar had in rice fields anywhere
already vincent and his team have
introduced biochar to tree nursery
owners
given that the charred husks can be used
solely on plants or into the high
nitrate and moisture retention
capabilities
[Music]
going forward as all these interventions
take shape cross-learning opportunities
will be critical to scaling up and
transforming rice farming to become more
sustainable given its important role in
addressing food nutrition security and
improved incomes for all the value chain
actors to find out more about our for
icsa project by kilimo trust visit their
website
www.kelimotrust.org
[Music]
you